tus luces ya prendidas todos se hacen la
misma pregunta navidad será la misma que
el año pasado después de la aparición de
la nueva variante de strasshof 2 omicron
a menos de un mes de las fiestas de fin
de año el rumbo de diciembre podría
estar afectado en sudáfrica donde se
descubrió la nueva variante el impacto
ya se hace sentir en plena temporada
alta en el país más visitado de áfrica
austral
veníamos por primera vez todo el mes de
diciembre reservado todos los
propietarios de hostales y hospedajes
nos dicen que todo el mundo canceló es
una muy mala noticia
riley ever news el impacto de un micrón
podría sentirse más allá de las
fronteras sudafricanas en europa por
ejemplo donde muchos países tienen su
esquema de vacunación superior al 70 por
ciento de la población el temor de un
regreso a un confinamiento forzado
durante las fiestas ya está presente la
capital alemana obliga a todos los que
quieren ingresar a su mercado de navidad
a tener su esquema de vacunación al día
hoy expositivos no tengo nada de qué
quejarme pero tengo un pequeño nudo en
el estómago no sabemos qué pasará si
varios dirigentes también se
pronunciaron sobre el tema por su parte
reino unido- prefiere exhibir su
optimismo estoy bastante seguro o
absolutamente seguro de que esta navidad
será considerablemente mejor que la
navidad pasada del otro lado del
atlántico la certeza no es tan grande
después de un black friday más que
decepcionante para muchos almacenes la
certeza por el momento reposa en la
vacunación que le vamos a tomar todas
las precauciones por eso hemos tomado
las medidas que tenemos si no ha
recibido la vacuna de refuerzo a ganar
en esta temporada tan esperada del año
la excepción podría ser grande para
varios países del mundo